c est une chanson de léo ferré vous la
connaissez bien et elle s'appelle joli
monde
et dites nous souhaitons pouilles à la
rue qui est même j'ai hâte rancoeurs à
conques où elle pas l'air joli mot alary
mais l'équipe l'otan ont cédé des gels
et des amants joliment la paruline ça
sent bon présentes dont nos amis joe
libre et qu'il fallait pas grandi sous
de l'air du temps technologiques très
jolis mots avec un grain de sel dans le
chagrin green
tech'innove ans qu'on est ensemble en
vous même un joli vizille son pointu
relaxe des petits seins sont du jour
quant à la barre hier dans le froid ça
pour cela faire du coup jolie môme la
vialette elles violent convia l'invs et
c'est bon j'ai limoux et qui nous ferait
pas sens qui sous l'ère et des temps
technitoit lele mora comtois leurs jours
chelimo
c'est qu'un point sur les des chagrins
le dit c'est qu'une chose les il faut
qu'on arrose publie shy'm monde là qui
ne démérite pas quelques taquineries mon
bonheur arrive ça peu taquiné sur son
milieu vite la bouche de jolis là qui
n'est pas valable en poussant chantal
fanny m'ont fait qu'une pauvre petite
fleur combinant vidéo qui ne pas citer
qu'eux sont avec moi si shalimar on sait
qu'ils ne serait dès lors qu'on essaye
même temps qu'une choix n'allait pas
chez lui l'a retrouvée je lui était tout
nu soul et la rive qui ne pouvait être
tenu son poulet et la guinée bull